und dann erlebt europa noch ein comeback
das die welt wirklich nicht braucht der
islamistische terror ist zurück es ist
eigentlich wenig überraschend denn auch
wenn der es kein richtiges territorium
er hat die kranke ideologie ist ja noch
da kurz hintereinander anschläge in
dresden paris nizza und zuletzt in wien
wo sich auch wenn es ausdrücklich nur
eine fußnote ist das fernsehen ziemlich
blamiert hat meine breaking news schon
klar aber können wir es nicht wieder so
machen wie früher
wissen sie doch als man erst was
berichtet hat wenn man auch wusste dass
es passiert ist
heute soll ich kollegen in echtzeit beim
raten zu gucken die berichte
überschlagen sich ja jetzt wir haben
jetzt gehört dass es auch eine
geiselnahme geben soll
jetzt gibt es auch eine geiselnahme in
einem hotel das lokal wo vielleicht
können wir dorthin summen da dürfte es
hier zu dieser geiselnahme gekommen
seien und diese geiselnahme soll in ein
restaurant namens akiko passiert sein
mehrere täter offensichtlich mindestens
vier täter sieben bis zehn täter bis zu
zehn tätern im hintergrund zieht man
hier viele häuser und auf den dächern
von diesen häusern auch dort könnten
sich scharfschützen der attentäter
gefunden haben
mein gott sie wissen es gab einen täter
und keine geiselnahme
also wenn vier tote und 23 verletzte
nicht schrecklich genug wie gesagt
fußnote die eigentliche frage lautet wie
wehrt sich europa jetzt dazu haben frau
merkel und die kollegen maicon kurz
diese woche konferiert sie fordern unter
anderem bessere grenzkontrolle nicht
verkehrt ändert aber nichts an den 620
gefährdern die schon in deutschland
lieben konsequente abschiebung heißt es
dann
was aber gar nicht geht wenn bestimmte
länder ihre leute nicht zurücknehmen
würde ich auch nicht machen
sie sind ja gefährlich die meisten von
denen kennen sich übrigens mit koran und
religion nicht wirklich aus die kommen
eher aus dem kleinen gangster milieu
wirklich so tatsache hier dieser imam
und gefängnisseelsorger erzählt mal mit
wem er es in seinen der radikalisierung
kursen im gefängnis so zu tun hat die
meisten sind ganz normale kriminelle
räuber einbrecher drogenhändler wenn es
eingeführt wird
wir unterscheiden versteht dann werden
die hälfte von euch wert und die andere
hälfte amputiert und soll ja gut die
firma portiert sind viele ja schon an
solchen präventionsprogramm führt kein
weg vorbei
selbst wenn sich einzelne täter wie der
in dresden im gefängnis radikalisieren
langfristig hilft sowieso nur mehr
integration und weniger
parallelgesellschaft es so ja wenn man
bei uns mit dem falschen namen
nachweislich probleme hat eine wohnung
oder ein job zu finden machen wir es den
islamisten vielleicht auch zu leicht
immerhin bildet deutschland ab 2021
endlich seine eigenen imame aus am
dienstag direkt nach der islamkonferenz
stolz verkündet vom innenminister wir
sorgen für unsere muslimischen bürger
und bürgerinnen selbst und die pid ohne
mehrfach wir sorgen für unsere
muslimischen bürgerinnen und bürger ich
betone mehrfach horst der islam gehört
nicht zu deutschland seehofer hat
neuerdings seine eigenen muslime ja
finde ich gut wirklich man muss das auch
mal loben wenn sich einer
weiterentwickelt bei uns leben 4,5
millionen muslime klar gehören die zu
deutschland und es ist viel besser
selber imame auszubilden
als es zum beispiel nur recep erdogan
und seiner ditib behörde zu überlassen
davos verlängerte arm in deutschland
nicht gut selbstverständlich lehnt eine
überwältigende mehrheit der muslime
extremismus ab bei themen wie mohammed
karikaturen gehen die meinungen
allerdings schon mal auseinander
dass man bei uns freiheit geht so weit
dass ist jemanden verletzt oder
angreifen so definiert sich die grenze
hier eigentlich nicht man kann
karikaturen furchtbar finden ja man kann
sich aufregen darüber öffentlich man
kann sich über die beschwerden oder
krise vorschlag sie einfach nicht
angucken aber insgesamt läuft das schon
unter kunstfreiheit und diese freiheit
würden wir gerne behalten
ich sage da muss man sogar geradezu
darauf bestehen dasselbe gilt wenn
muslimische eltern in der schule druck
machen weil ihnen unterrichtsthemen wie
der holocaust nicht passen wenn die
schüler heute da nachgibt gibt sie zwei
signale aus dass eine signal ist
wir nehmen das gar nicht so erst mit
unseren werten und das zweite signal ist
ihr könnt machen was wir wollen wir sind
schwach schule darf aber nicht sein
sehr richtig schule darf stinklangweilig
seien aber nie schwach und ganz wichtig
bei all dem geht es eben nicht um wir
gegen die gar nicht oder um den clash of
cultures den feuchten traum der
extremisten feinde der offenen
gesellschaft findet man in vielen lagern
und manchmal sind die schnittmengen
größer als man denkt na du findest
einfach keinen partner weil du einfach
viel zu extrem bist zu brutal zu
intolerant wir haben das perfekte match
für dich
wirklich da gibt es ohne ende gemeinsame
interessen
ihr liebt beide gewalt und hass schwule
juden und das grundgesetz ernsthaft ihr
seid wie für einander gemacht also traut
euch jetzt anmelden bei extremisten
partner.de alle elf sekunden verlieben
sich ein islamist und ein nazi wenn es
nach mir geht dürfen sie sogar heiraten
das gute ist wir haben in deutschland
meinungs- und religionsfreiheit ist doch
schön und wenn die mal in konflikt
geraten und man nicht weiter weiß dann
fragt man einfach den großen versöhner
gernot hassknecht
gernot hassknecht erklärt alles
wesentliche zu religion und
meinungsfreiheit in 165 sekunden immer
zuerst vor der eigenen türe kehren ja
wir medien müssten mehr über
integrationserfolge berichten über ein
viertel unserer neuen firmen wurden
letztes jahr von bürgern mit
migrationshintergrund gegründet auch mal
die guten nachrichten erfahrene
schrieben wir haben inzwischen mehr
migrantinnen und migranten die auch
einen schulabschluss machen das sind
immer noch zu viele
ja genau oder so ähnlich
gleichzeitig müssen wir aber auch unsere
werte als auch von einer gesellschaft
entschieden verteidigen hier bei uns
gibt es genau ein heiliges buch dass
hier jeder darf glauben was er will aber
religiöse gefühle sind keine juristische
kategorie sonst muss ich als nächstes
rücksicht nehmen auf die gefühle von
kann keine ahnung dass die züchter noder
diesen kanon leuten die glauben bill
gates kinder blut manche spieler glauben
sogar dass schalke nicht absteigt
alles völlig okay die dürfen das glauben
ich darf witze darüber machen wenn das
smartphone ein präsident ein präsident
können wir kritisieren das ist was nur
ganz normal ist aber ich kann jetzt
nicht einen gesandten von alex
kritisieren
doch man muss das nicht schon gar nicht
um menschen zu beleidigen aber natürlich
darf man in einem säkularen land auch
religionen kritisieren streichen wir
endlich den bescheuerten blasphemie
paragraphen 166 aus dem strafrecht wir
erleben doch bitte leben wir doch in
einer eine religion beleidigt dann ist
das so als ob man meine mutter beleidigt
und dafür riskiert man dann schon mal
einen kinnhaken das ist doch normal
normal also deine mutter wirklich nichts
gegen religion aber wir müssen
meinungsfreiheit und offene debatten
verteidigen beispiel der deutsche
lehrerverband sagt an bestimmten
brennpunktschulen dort sich lehrer nicht
mehr themen wie israel und den nahen
osten zu behandeln wohl auf druck von
muslimischen eltern zum glück nur
einzelfälle
trotzdem kann es da nur eine antwort
geben
aus prinzip vier fenstern im unterricht
behandeln und zwar in allen fächern
inklusive physik kunst und sport große
pause ich gehe einen rauchen münchen ja
it-service beweise sprechen mit jürgen
wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus und
wieder einzuschalten hat nichts gebracht
verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung